hi we have this question on our quiz  where some of you asked why it's the  convolutional neural network's depth  that increases the field of view or  context window in other words this is a  case where a picture is worth more than  a youtube comment so here's the  visualized explanation increasing the  kernel size in a cnn also increases the  context window since the output is  directly informed by more pixels but  this would be a very costly way to do it  since the parameter number scales  quadratically with kernel size having  more of these kernels or filters does  help with feature diversity but has  nothing to do with the field of view but  having a deep cnn with one convolutional  layer one after the other greatly  increases the field of view in a  nutshell if the output after the first  layer is this and was informed by the  whole region of 4 pixels then the next  convolution layer aggregates again 4  pixels but now one of them is already  informed by 4 others  okay bye